Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen.
Es geht bergab. Ja, mit dem Programm hier. Es geht bergab. Ja. Klickt keiner mehr.
Es geht bergab, ja. Klingt keiner mehr. Der Intendant der Meterebene hat mir gerade schon einen Rüffel erteilt und gesagt, ich soll mehr Titten bringen.
Tja, ich weiß nicht, ob wir das hier so durchziehen können irgendwie. Hohe Erwartungen ans Programm.
Unter hundert Flatter im letzten Podcast weit unter hundert Flittern.
Das war eine super Sendung. War die beste Sendung. Ja. Neunundzwanzig.
War die beste Sendung. War die beste Sendung. Ich würde ja jetzt sagen, hört euch die nochmal an, aber wahrscheinlich hört die Sendung noch weniger Leute.
Nee, also von von Hörerzahlen ist ja super, aber die Hörer sind knausriger geworden. Das Geld sitzt nicht mehr so locker.
Das Geld sitzt nicht mehr so laut. Boah, ein Podcast, Stabilitätspakt. Ja.
Und zwar lautet dieser Pakt wie folgt, ihr geht jetzt mal alle schön im Internet und drückt die Flatterknöpfe.
Also so richtig beklagen können wir uns eigentlich nicht. Das zeigt sich nur, dass äh nachdem Instacaster als aufm Deckel bekommen hat, dass das dann sozusagen diese Klickzahlen tatsächlich nachhaltig äh beeinflussen,
glaube ich nicht, dass der Zuspruch hier in irgendeiner Form zurückgegangen ist, sondern es hat sich einfach nur äh das Klickverhalten äh den Realitäten angepasst, den technischen Realitäten angepasst.
Ja. Glücklicherweise äh ist Tim das ziemlich egal, weil wenn insgesamt weniger Stücke Kuchen verteilt werden, sind natürlich auch die Stücke, die man kriegt, größer,
ausreichend nach wie vor für die für die für das Füttern der Kinder, also.
Verzerren, wenn man das Bild hier nicht komplett hier. Wir sind dankbar für jede Unterstützung. Und wichtig ist das nicht, sondern wichtig ist, dass hier ordentliche Sendungen produziert werden.
Äh da bemühen wir uns doch einfach mal, dass es diese Woche auch wieder was wird. Und dazu haben wir uns auch gleich einen sexy Killerthema genommen, wo alle alle sofort drauf anspringen.
Da gab's eine richtige Party hier letzte Woche, ne?
Ja, die GEMA hat sich ja mit den, mit den Clubs angelegt und die haben hier dann einfach mal vor der Kalkschweine oder was war, wo die, wo die Gamer sich dann da getroffen,
Franzklub, ja genau, aber die Gamer-Wahl war die GEMA im Franzklub. Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass, ja, war die.
Party war da. Also die haben sozusagen direkt vor ihrer, ich weiß gar nicht, was da was der Anlass war, war das.
Irgend so eine Versammlung oder so jährliche. Direkt vor der Tür haben.
Mehr so eine Party eigentlich. Direkt vor der Tür haben. Und vor der Party gab's dann nochmal eine andere Party. Dann standen sie da mit dicken Lastwagen. Warst du da?
Ja, ja. Und haben dann da äh gesagt, dass das alles irgendwie nix ist mit der GEMA.
Hm
Ich bin nur kurz vorbeigefahren. Ich äh hatte noch, musste noch einen Podcast aufnehmen vorher, deswegen hatte ich eigentlich keine richtige Zeit. Kam also vorbei, da lag das gerade so in den letzten Zügen, aber merkte irgendwie da war's äh schön äh schön laut,
und ähm da wurde auf jeden Fall eine Menge Heckmeck äh gemacht und die Veranstaltung kam glaube ich äh insgesamt ganz gut rüber auch äh obwohl Doktor Motte da noch eine Rede gehalten hat, oder?
Ja, also ähm war auf jeden Fall ganz gut und äh ich habe,
ich war auch jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit da, ich bin auch nur kurz, habe mich das angeschaut, waren ja auch mehrere LKWs mit Musik und so, eine ganze äh Allee irgendwie abgesperrt oder ein großer Teil der Schönhausallee. Ähm.
Und ich habe, war mir das so ein bisschen angehört und ähm man man dachte so, ja, jetzt will die GEMA irgendwie den Clubs irgendwie die Gebühren erhöhen, aber wenn man sich dann mal anschaut, wie sehr die die erhöhen wollen, dann äh kommt man dann doch mal so ins ähm Nachfragen.
Und das äh haben natürlich dann auch die Medien gemacht, da gab's ein wunderschönes ähm Interview mit dieser Gabi Schlicher,
äh die in der Berliner Zeitung dann da so so richtig den gesamten Charme der spielen lassen. Äh es war ich kann mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen
dass die ähm also entweder die Leute bei der GEMA sind inzwischen völlig abgehoben oder die es inzwischen arbeitslos. Also das kann ich mir echt nicht vorstellen, weißt du was die da von sich gegeben hat. Auf jeden Fall hat.
Was hattest du daran auszusetzen?
Es war einfach von einer Arroganz geprägt ähm also sie sie beendet äh dass das Interview mit äh dass sich mein anstrengendes Gespräch mit ihnen das ich für mein anstrengendes Gespräch mit ihnen bezahlt werde, ist ja wohl klar.
Also damit beendet die das Interview, ja.
Oh Mann, ey.
Aber genau.
Gott, ja okay, alles klar. Stuhl eigentlich schon wackeln.
Fangen wir mal kurz mit mit äh mit mit äh kurz an, von Geld zu reden. Also GEMA ist ja für die Komponistente Texter, Musikverleger,
und sorgt dafür, dass die eben hier in Geld kommen. Wir hatten äh da gab's einen sehr schönen Artikel in der Frankfurter Rundschau, wo dann mal so gesagt wurde, also alle Zahlen, die ich jetzt die Tiere sieht von zweitausendzehn, da haben sie achthundertdreiundsechzig Millionen Euro eingenommen,
Achthundertdreiundsechzig. Ähm und erstmal,
hundertsiebenundzwanzig Millionen Euro hat die dann erstmal selber verschlungen. Ja, also bei sich irgendwie verteilt. Das geht dann irgendwie äh haben ungefähr tausend Mitarbeiter,
und äh für diese tausend Mitarbeiter mussten erstmal hundertsiebenundzwanzig Millionen Euro irgendwie innerhalb der GEMA selber verbraten werden, weil die Vorstände so zwischen einer Viertel und einer halben Million
Jahresgehalt haben und dann haben sie noch drei die irgendwie unterhalten werden und so weiter.
Also fünfzehn Prozent gehen sozusagen drauf für maintenance. Mhm.
Und dann haben dann bleiben ja siebenhundertfünfunddreißig Millionen Euro über. Die werden ausgeschüttet
an die insgesamt äh fünfundsechzigtausend Mitglieder. Wenn man da jetzt einen Durchschnitt bilden würde, würde man so also sagen, das wären so circa elftausend Euro pro GEMA-Mitglied pro Jahr wieder so,
verteilt werden. Ähm.
Fünfundsechzigtausend Mitglieder. Ja. Mhm.
Und jetzt, jetzt, jetzt kommt's aber, jetzt äh ist die haben nicht fünfundsechzigtausend gleichberechtigte Mitglieder, sondern erstmal von den fünfundsechzigtausend, sind vierundachtzig Prozent
angeschlossene Mitglieder, die haben keine Rechte, können da also auch nicht irgendwie innerhalb dieses Vereins mitbestimmen. Dann gibt's elf Prozent außerordentliche Mitglieder. Die haben etwas eingeschränkte Stimmrecht und ähm,
den Anspruch auf die gemer Sozialkasse.
Und dann gibt's dreitausendvierhundert ordentliche Mitglieder. Das sind also fünf Prozent und die haben also eine Stimmberechtigung in der Mitgliederversammlung und ähm,
halten den Laden da, also sortieren den Laden und und ähm richten auch aus, wie da die Gebührenordnung,
Ähm ist. Und das Schöne ist, sie haben also dieses dieses Pro-Verfahren in ihrem, wie sie also intern ausschütten.
Und ähm das heißt, also das der Pro Faktor ist quasi ein Faktor, den der, den der äh,
Stück oder der Künstler hat auf jeden Fall je öfter ein Stück gespielt wird, desto mehr Ausschüttungen gibt es pro Aufführung,
Das heißt, das das steigt nicht linear an, der der Gewinn, den du mit einem Stück machst, sondern der steigt exponentiell an,
weil der quasi die Ausschüttung pro äh pro Wiedergabe eben auch mit ansteigt,
Und das ist natürlich eine recht starke äh Bevorteiligung der ähm sagen wir mal großen Stars. Ja,
Also irgendwelche.
Was ist da die äh Argumentation, dass das so ist?
Da brauchen ja nicht zu argumentieren, weil ja die ordentlichen Mitglieder sowieso die großen Stars sind und sie die einzigen, letztendlich sind, die nennenswerte äh Stimmanteile in der Mitgliederversammlung haben. Also es gibt noch irgendwie
vierundsechzig Delegierte der außerordentlichen und angeschlossenen Mitglieder in der Mitgliederversammlung. Aber ähm,
die äh leisten da ja keinen nennenswerten Stimmbrei.
Und das äh äußert sich dann in der äh,
in der Realität dann dadurch, dass also wenn jetzt ein Konzertveranstalter also irgendein kleiner, wenn irgendein kleiner Gamer,
oder irgendein Musiker dann irgendwie bei so einem Konzertveranstalter seine Lieder spielt muss der Konzertveranstalter sei es jetzt eine Kneipe, sei es eine äh große Halle, eine Liste an die GEMA schicken, welche Stücke da gespielt wurden,
Und das muss dann natürlich auch der Konzertveranstalter bezahlen. Also wenn ich ein Konzertveranstalter kommt einer hin und spielt irgendwie GEMA Musik, da muss ich bezahlen, dass diese Musik aufgefüllt wurde.
Und von diesem Geld sollte natürlich dann eigentlich der Künstler,
Wenn er die Lieder selber geschrieben hat, natürlich auch eigentlich dieses Geld wieder bekommen. Durch diesen Profaktor äh kommt es aber dazu, dass das äh dass die Ausschüttung eben,
sich eher auf die konzentriert, die sehr häufig im Radio gespielt werden. Weil es gibt einen sehr großen Anteil an nicht ähm,
zuschreibbarem Geld, also ähm beispielsweise die ganzen Pauschalsachen, die jetzt irgendwie eine Kneipe schickt ja nicht jedes Mal eine Liste, sondern die haben irgendwie so einen Pauschalrahmenvertrag.
Mhm.
Und ähm.
Auch häufig, also.
Genau und das geht dann häufig so in das geht dann eher in diese Sozialkasse, das heißt, da profitieren dann wieder nur die ordentlichen und außerordentlichen äh oder genau die ordentlichen und außerordentlichen Mitglieder, die Anspruch auf diese Sozialkasse haben, also es ist ein insgesamt.
So, das heißt, wenn wenn es nicht eine defizite Liste ist, dann wird es gar nicht an alle ausgeschüttet, sondern es geht nur in diese Sozialkasse und das betrifft nur diese dreitausendvierhundert Leute.
Dreitausendvierhundert plus nochmal die anderen elf Prozent, das müssten dann nochmal so sechstausend oder so sein, ne? Sechs siebentausend außerordentliche Mitglieder. Also ungefähr.
Achso, die Außerordentlichen, ordentlich, außerordentlich und angeschlossene Mitglieder. Oh man, okay,
und wenn's eine Liste ist, heißt es auch nicht, dass automatisch die was kriegen, die auf dieser Liste sind, sondern nur, dass,
theoretisch äh ihr Account irgendwie hochgeht und sie vielleicht unter Umständen mal in diesen Bereich reinkommen, wo es eine gewisse Achselleration gibt. Aber wenn die anderen sozusagen immer noch mehr haben, kriegen sie auch über Gebühr mehr,
Also nicht linear und nicht im direkten Verhältnis zu dem wie häufig sie gespielt wurden, sondern weil sie da in einer anderen Klasse sind, unter Umständen ein Mehrfaches, obwohl sie nicht ein Mehrfaches gespielt worden sind. Weiher.
Genau, du, du, genau, du, du machst quasi mit, jede tausend, die du öfter gespielt wirst, machst du mehr,
mehr Gewinn pro tausend, ja? Und da,
Während sich also alle Möglichen gegen und wird irgendwie auch Bohlensteuer genannt, weil es also quasi, weil alle ja äh latzen müssen. Also zum Beispiel auch äh gibt ja auch diese GEMA-Abgaben auf äh USB-Sticks und so weiter, ne? Die werden übrigens, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, jetzt am
Montag erhöht am ersten Juli. Er wurde die Abgabe auf USB-Sticks und Speichermedien von vormals zehn Cent,
auf ein Euro fünfundneunzig, gehen an die.
USB-Stick.
Ist wichtig, ja? Weil du.
Produkt, was es demnächst sozusagen eigentlich so für zwanzig Cent mal geben sollte, ne, wenn man mal so ein Gigabyte sich schoppt. Kann aber nicht für zwanzig Cent verkauft werden, weil.
Ja, ein riesiger Schaden da entsteht. Also ich glaube, das Verständnis dafür wird äh auf ein Minimum sinken in der nächsten Zeit.
Vor allem das ist sehr schön, das sind tausendachthundertfünfzig Prozent, ne? Wenn du irgendwie von von zehn Cent auf eins fünfundneunzig gehst, ja. Ähm.
Meine USB-Sticks ja auch nur um Musik zu verteilen, muss ich.
Ja natürlich, klar, ne, aber.
Noch nie eine andere Anwendung dafür gehabt.
Das ist das ist sowieso sehr witzig, wie die wie die die Rechtsgrundlage der GEMA, da es geht ja noch weiter. Ähm und zwar gibt es ja die die GEMA Vermutung,
Das ist sehr schön, weil wenn du ähm wenn du jetzt irgendwie eine Musikveranstaltung machst und spielst da GEMA-freie,
Musik, dann liegt die Beweislast auf dir und nicht auf der GEMA. Das heißt, wenn da irgendwie Musik gespielt wird und es ist unklar, ob dieser Künstler in der Gamer ist oder nicht,
Dann gilt die Gamervermutung, der ist in der GEMA. Und ähm da gibt's jetzt gerade einen sehr schönen Latti Gamer sich auch sehr beliebt gemacht,
die Musikpiraten, die machen einmal im Jahr den Free Music Contest, wo dann so CC lizenzierte Musik ähm.
Mhm. Also vor allem nicht GEMA-Musik.
Nicht GEMA, komplett frei lizensierte Musik irgendwie in so ein ein Wettbewerb tritt und am Ende gibt's ein,
ein Album, was sie dann daraus machen, das kann man dann.
Ähm runterladen oder ich glaube auch kaufen, um den um die Musikpiraten da irgendwie als Verein zu unterstützen oder so. Und ähm,
gab's jetzt irgendwie eine eine Band, die unter pseudonym,
oder eine eine Band, die ja einen Bandnamen, ja? Es steht ein Bandname und gibt's ein Lied. Und dann sagt die GEMA, hier äh die die treten unter Pseudonym auf und nicht unter dieses Pseudonym ist bei uns nicht gemappt mit einem bürgerlichen Namen,
gehen wir davon aus, dass das einer unserer Gamer-Künstler ist, der ähm.
Hier anonym.
Der hier anonym etwa, äh der hier anonym auftritt und deswegen hätten wir gerne ähm das Geld dafür.
Irgendwie hier online Bereitstellung pipapo, ne, schicken wir euch eine Rechnung und ähm,
Jetzt müsst ihr quasi erstmal beweisen, dass wir auch immer dieses Liter eingetragen hat, nicht in der GEMA ist, sonst wollen wir das Geld haben. Und damit sind die erstmal ähm,
tatsächlich juristisch gesehen im Recht. Und deswegen hat der Musikpiratenverein natürlich gesagt, seid ihr bekloppt so hier oben, ja,
das Geld abholen, hier oben und ähm dann hat die Geber gesagt, ja klar, okay, prima, dann verklagen wir euch. Jetzt freuen sich die Musik-Piraten.
Für die neue Aufmerksamkeit.
Für die neue Aufmerksamkeit diese diese CC-lizenzierte Band ähm Texas, Radio, Fisch oder so hieß die, glaube ich,
freut sich natürlich auch. Und das spannende daran ist, ich hatte das ja schon mal erwähnt hier, dass,
CC Lizenzen war da, sie werkbasiert sind, nicht mit den GEMA-Lizenzmodellen vereinbar sind, da diese auf den Künstler bezogen sind.
Und das also wirklich eine in der Tat eine, also unter Kleinkünstlern gehöre ich das auch, wird das auch so gesagt, dass es quasi eine Falle ist,
in die GEMA einzutreten, weil du natürlich auch nichts so einfach dort wieder rauskommst. Da gibt's irgendwie so 'ne Übergangsfrist, die Doktor Motte hatte das in irgend so einem Interview erzählt,
Ähm dass, wenn man aus dem Gamer-Vertrag aussteigen will, muss man zwei Jahre warten, bis die ganzen Kompositionen dann auch GEMA-frei sind.
Mhm. Ähm also bis auch alle Neuen Kompositionen, GEMA-frei sind.
Äh
gehe jetzt erstmal von dem bisherigen aus, aber der Doktor Motte sagt dann, äh wenn ich heute den Vertrag mit der GEMA als Autor kündige und einen,
und in einem Monat eine neue Komposition habe, dann verlängert sich die Wartezeit auch um einen weiteren Monat. Und das heißt,
legt er so aus, das ist ja auch richtig. Das würde also ein Berufsverbot äh gleichkommen. Das heißt, du müsstest aus der GEMA austreten und zwei Jahre nichts machen. Ähm,
Das heißt, du kommst da, also wenn das so stimmt, wie gesagt, äh Quelle Internet,
Äh wenn da äh eine Quelle Doktor Motte, wenn das so stimmt, dann wäre das natürlich äh ganz besonders schlimm, ne? Aber ist natürlich auch zumindest verständlich, dass die Gamer nicht zulassen kann, dass da andauernd die Leute rein und rausgehen
weil ähm der administrative Aufwand natürlich für die auch enorm hoch wäre.
Naja, ich meine, wenn sie eh schon fünfzehn Prozent von dieser Kohle einnehmen, irgendwas müssen sie ja tun. Was mich halt auch, also ist, es gibt wirklich so viele Stellen, wo man äh mitm Kopf gegen die Wand äh rennen will, wenn man sich mit diesem Thema äh beschäftigt.
Was ich zum Beispiel auch absurd finde, ist so dieses, du wirst zwar angehalten, da ausführliche Listen zu machen, ja, aber auch im Jahre.
Was haben wir jetzt? Zwanzigzwölf. Ja? Ist es halt so, dass dann so Radiomoderatoren wirklich ernsthaft Namen und Titel eintippen?
Äh wo ich mich A
Frage, warum gibt es nicht so etwas wie eine GEMA-ID, ja, also wenn diese Tracks GEMA geschützt sind und diese
Produzenten diese Werke in die Öffentlichkeit geben? Warum registrieren sie sie dann nicht gleich bei der GEMA und kriegen eine ID und diese ID ist in irgendeiner Form,
darin enthalten und.
Also das ist schon mal das erste Absurde. Also es wird einem auch extrem schwer gemacht, solche Listen überhaupt zu erstellen und vor allem macht's sich ja die GEMA auch extrem schwer,
Diese Listen in irgendetwas Zuordnung zuordnen, Bares umzusetzen, was einem natürlich irgendwie, also da kann man jetzt sagen,
okay, die sind einfach noch so ewig gestrig, dass sie sich das halt am liebsten per Fax schicken lassen. Bla bla. Ja, mag ja auch Leute geben, die irgendwie nicht über die notwendigen elektronischen Kommunikationsmittel verfügen, aber ich meine, das muss jetzt auch langsam mal ein Ende finden und,
es macht so ein bisschen auch den Eindruck, ich will das jetzt nicht unterstellen, aber der Eindruck entsteht natürlich, dass sie irgendwie auch gar kein Interesse an diesen Listen haben.
Genau, das, das haben sie auch nicht, also es ist in der Tat so, dass es entsteht für die einadministrativer Aufwand und so, wie sie die Kohle umverteilen wollen, also wie es im Interesse der der ordentlichen Mitglieder ist, müssen diese Listen nicht allzu genau geführt werden.
Einerseits nicht genauer geführt werden, beziehungsweise auch viel Motivation da, äh dass sie gar nicht geführt werden, weil in dem Moment kriegen sie ja auch die Kohle, aber exklusiv, ne,
sehr exklusiv und das dann eben auch noch als Sozialkasse, also potenziell sozusagen auch noch als Langzeitzahlung, ne? Und nicht als einmalige ähm,
Ausgabe, wobei ich jetzt nicht weiß, ob Betrag X dann in eine Mehrfachzahlung in der Zukunft quasi als Rente äh führt oder ob das dann sozusagen das nur eins zu eins finanziert.
Es gibt halt, es gibt halt eine schöne äh schöne Zahlen, wo dann irgendwie so einfach mal gesagt wird, so wie viel
kriegen denn diese und ich wende, ah, jetzt müsste ich das rausholen, aber wenn ich mich nicht täusche, äh gehen fast fünfundsechzig Prozent der Ausschüttungen
an diese ähm fünf Prozent.
Zwei Drittel.
Ja, wenn ich dir also die Zahl, die habe ich jetzt gerade nicht im, jetzt muss ich ganz kurz schauen, aber es ist auf jeden.
Mich jetzt nicht überraschen, ne?
Also in diesem Bereich bewegt sich das also ein ein sehr, sehr nennenswerter Anteil geht nur an diese wenigen dreitausend ordentlichen Mitglieder und ähm ich.
Und das vor allem für die Nutzung von Werken, die sie überhaupt gar nicht äh gemacht haben, ne.
Und jetzt kommt aber das äh du sagtest das ja gerade mit der Liste, dass alles ein bisschen bisschen kompliziert. Deswegen macht die GEMA jetzt auch eine Tarifrform,
und sagt, ja ähm also sie hat ja dann also ich weiß zum Beispiel bei Kneipen, da gibt's dann irgendwie so einen Standardtarif und ähm wenn du dann gebrannte CDs ähm auflegen möchtest, dann kostet das mehr oder so, da haben sie irgendwie so Pauschal Deals, ne?
Ähm.
Obwohl für die gebrannten CDs ja auch schon bezahlt hast?
Und MP3-Player anzuschließen und so, das kostet dann alles extra, es sind also relativ komplizierte Modelle. Und jetzt haben sie gesagt, ja, da haben wir elf Tarif, ist ja alles total blöd.
Und jetzt machen wir einfach mal nur noch zwei. Ist alles viel leichter. Und für die Clubs, also für Diskotheken wird's noch viel einfacher. Da wollen wir einfach zehn Prozent des Eintritts von der Tür.
Und damit ähm seid ihr alle sorgenlos. Einfacher Pauschaltarif, außer wenn eure ähm Veranstaltung länger als fünf Stunden dauert, dann hätten wir gerne fünfzig Prozent mehr,
und äh fünfzig.
Fünfzehn Prozent, also fünfzehn Prozent des Eintritts.
Ja und pro weitere drei Stunden nochmal fünfzig Prozent. Das heißt, ein, sagen wir mal, ein Berliner Club, der irgendwie seine guten ähm zwanzig Stunden aufhat oder so oder lass den nur lass dir nur
Lasse nur fünfzehn aufhaben oder zwölf, ja, ähm,
Keine Ahnung, da müssen sie ähm brauche ich jetzt gar nicht auszurichten, da gab's schon Rechenbeispiele, äh eine Großdisko, wo damals so zu Grunde gelegt hat, bisher so vielleicht,
vierzigtausend im Jahr gezahlt,
und landet jetzt nach dieser ähm Reform ungefähr bei dreihunderttausend. Auf die auf die Berliner Clubs bezogen im Schnitt äh statt achtundzwanzigtausend
Euro pro Jahr jetzt hundertvierundsiebzigtausend. Das ist so die den Durchschnitt der Berliner Club, ja?
Ja, wir wissen ja auch, dass Clubbetreiber irgendwie im äh im Mama nur so baden, ne? Also alle Clubbetreiber, die ich kenne, also die haben alle Hände voll mit Gold. Ja. Und fahre nur die dicksten Autos.
Vor allem, äh wenn das, wenn das Geld vom Eintritt genommen wird, kann man sich ja unglaublich schwer vorstellen, wo die Clubbetreiber das als nächstes sofort drauf umlegen, ne? Wahrscheinlich auf die Bierpreise
Also ich weiß, am nahe ist, ist halt ganz klar, dass ähm dass die Eintrittspreise dadurch enorm steigen werden müssen,
weil äh du musst ja überlegen, diese diese zehn Prozent. Und jetzt gehen wir mal beim Club, so der heißt halt auf jeden Fall länger als fünf Stunden auf, wäre er bei acht, sagen wir mal so, ähm
zwanzig Prozent, wenn das dann ungefähr zwanzig Prozent des Eintritts und das aber brutto, ne? Das heißt, du zahlst von mir aus irgendwie äh zehn Euro, da sind ja noch die ganzen Steuern drin, aber zwei Euro gehen schon mal an die an die GEMA.
Also völlig, völlig äh völlig unverständlich, ja. Was äh was da los ist?
Diese Beweis ja, ich meine es gibt ja so Systeme wie,
äh ich überlege jetzt grade, man müsste jetzt, glaube ich, es ist wird sich Zeit, kreativ zu werden und zwar sowohl juristisch kreativ, weil ich aus meinem äh äh aus meinem Ianal äh Verständnis heraus ähm,
denke ich, ist da eine Menge drin, was einfach generell nicht zu halten ist, rechtlich.
Ja, also grad dieser Berufsverbot, äh Aspekt et cetera, also die faktische Unmöglichkeit, da eigentlich auszusteigen. Ich meine, das kann ja wohl nicht sein, dass ein Vertrag äh äh dir verbietet, deinen Beruf auszuüben. Ja.
Also laut meiner Information geht eben der äh Doktor Motte ja auch dagegen vor. Andererseits ähm würde die GEMA ja argumentieren. Na ja, ja. Äh warum willst du denn aus der Gamer austreten?
Weil die scheiße sind und auch so so stinken. Also ich meine, das ist ja wohl äh äh ganz klar. So, aber jetzt äh ich versuche jetzt gerade nochmal so ein bisschen äh zu sehen, weil,
ich denke, wir haben hier mit dem Thema Gamer und Urheberrecht sicherlich den Tipping Point noch nicht erreicht, aber ich habe äh die Diskussion schon lange nicht mehr so schnell den Berg hochklettern,
sehen. Und ähm diese Creative Commons äh äh Geschichte.
Bisher ja immer so ein belächeltes, schönes HH, der ja äh ja die paar Songs und so weiter schön gedacht, ne. Und jetzt hat man eben auch noch so dieses Problem mit mit dieser Beweislast,
technisch lösen. Ich meine, generell könnte man sowieso frage ich mich, wie kann die GEMA nicht feststellen, dass etwas,
nicht der GEMA unterliegt, weil sie müssen ja ihre Stücke ja wohl kennen,
also finde ich derzeit meinen sie wahrscheinlich nur nö, wir müssen nur unsere Mitglieder kennen, das reicht uns und wahrscheinlich ist da, wenn ihr irgendwas spielt und wir wissen nicht genau, was das ist oder von wem das ist, dann ist es wahrscheinlich äh von einem von uns, auch wenn wir das nicht kennen,
ja? Aber das halte ich zum Beispiel schon mal für extrem angreifbar,
Ja, weil es kann ja wohl nicht sein, dass ein Mitglied, was da drin ist, selber nicht weiß, was es produziert hat, also müsste man es ja sehr wohl dazu zwingen können, äh jetzt sagen wir mal, auf dem rechtlichen Weg, dass die, gehen wir das selber tun könnte, ist auch klar, aber daran haben sie wahrscheinlich derzeit kein Interesse,
Also würde man jetzt die Mitglieder dazu zwingen, zu sagen, okay, hier und das ist auch das, was ich jetzt tatsächlich produziert habe und ich bin euch gegenüber verpflichtet, euch das auch anzuzeigen,
Ist da einfach so ein Musical Fingerprint? Ich meine, ich kann heutzutage so ein iPhone hoch halten und starten und äh kriege die meisten Bekannten, die da irgendwie erkannt. Also es ist überhaupt
nicht so, dass es brutal unmöglich wäre, das schnell herauszubekommen. Da muss man jetzt nicht äh über Unique Problematiken beim äh Suchen von äh Autorenamen diskutieren.
So und äh das heißt einerseits könnte man die GEMA auch in so eine so ein so ein.
Position bringen, dass man sagt, so, ihr habt viel bessere Möglichkeiten, da eure Ansprüche auch wirklich selber zu überprüfen,
Auf der anderen Seite, wenn ich jetzt überlege, ich mache jetzt einen will jetzt einen Club machen, der einfach überhaupt gar keinen Bock mehr hat auf diese ganze GEMA-Geschichte, sondern natürlich erstmal knallhart, weil das heißt.
Ein riesiger Berg, cooler Musik, fällt irgendwie weg für dich. Ja, aber wenn ihr jetzt wirklich so ein CC-Club aufmachen wollen würdest, so, ja?
Müsstest du wahrscheinlich hier selber äh mit so einem Musikerkennungssoftware äh hinkommen. Du müsstest allen DJs,
quasi so ein gewisses Softwareprotokoll äh vorschreiben, was ihr da auflegt. Ich meine, die liegen ja eh fast alle in zunehmenden Maße digital auf, ist ja auch völlig in Ordnung, warum nicht?
So, das heißt, äh man sammelt das quasi auch automatisiert ein,
Ich denke, es wird dich über so einen so einen totalen die Zukunft voll äh automatisierten äh nachweislich gema freien äh Club nach.
Und äh der im Übrigen auch in der Lage wäre, höhere äh ähm Tanzemen zu zahlen,
weil er ja nicht die zwanzig Prozent an die GEMA äh abgeben muss.
Ja. Das das wäre, ja?
Also es äh entwickelt sich ja langsam auch zu einem Marktvorteil.
Der hätte aber natürlich das Problem, dass die GEMA ihn wahrscheinlich die ganze Zeit nerven würde.
Ja, deswegen muss man sie ja, darüber rede ich ja gerade. Man muss sich da sozusagen technisch auch absichern. Ja. Ja, und das auf eine Art und Weise machen,
ähm ja äh wasserdicht ist natürlich eine andere Geschichte, aber die Frage ist ja am Ende, bist du äh einem Gericht gegenüber auch ausreichend glaubwürdig. Und wenn du jetzt wirklich ein System hast,
was erstmal so eine Softwareherausforderung ist, aber sowas lässt sich ja äh immer schnell,
auch lösen, ja, wo du sagst, okay, alle DJs, die hier auflegen, alle Leute, die hier selber ihre Sachen machen
irgendwie 'n Musical Fingerprint, 'ne ID, keine Ahnung, müssen ihren Song irgendwo in der Datenbank registriert haben und diese Zahlen wollen wir irgendwie haben
ja? Wenn's die Software nicht automatisch selber liefert. Ja,
So, das ist jetzt so ein bisschen meine ähm zurecht gemalte äh Lieblingszukunft, ja,
Die Frage, ob so ein Club dann erstmal äh das äh entsprechende musikalische Repertoire hat, um Leute irgendwie glücklich zu machen, aber.
Piratenpartei hielt man ja auch mal für total unmöglich und unvorstellbar.
Du, also ich höre einige CC-Musik, die mir auch durchaus gefällt.
Ja, ich meine, es gibt mittlerweile da gute Sachen, aber wenn man vor allem auch sagen kann, okay, äh wir wir haben ja aber auch einen einen auch für die Komponisten.
Klicken sozusagen in dem Moment, wo ein Song äh gespielt wird, auch gleich den passenden äh Flatterbutton dazu,
jetzt mal weiter gedacht, also nicht nur die DJs, die auflegen, kriegen automatisch einen Anteil aus diesen Eintrittseinnahmen, sondern auch,
alles freiwillig natürlich irgendwie, weil da gibt's ja jetzt keine Verpflichtungen dafür, aber ich denke auf der Basis müsste man das Ganze mal denken. Wir haben ja hatten ja jetzt hier Eingangs quasi so diese Insta-Cast
Problematik äh induzierte äh Einstiegsdiskussion. Wenn ich das jetzt mal auf Musik
zurück übersetze, so wie dieses oh ich habe den Podcast automatisch gehört, er wird dann automatisch geflettert, wenn man das eben dann sozusagen auch in Clubs transferiert
ähm ähm für dort gespielte Musik, ja, könnte sich an der Stelle auch ein interessanter Mechanismus entwickeln.
Würde sogar, wer noch ein weiter interessanter Aspekt zu beobachten, denn wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche, ist es, mit der GEMA so zu verstehen, dass die im Moment,
Also sie haben so eine Art Flächenberechnung, ja, also wie gesagt, ähm für den ganzen Kleinkram machen die ja eh irgendwelche Pauschalverträge, ne? Und ähm
da berechnen sie dann eben nach nach Fläche. Und wenn du jetzt so eine Konzertveranstaltest, ist es nach meinen Informationen auch äh
momentan äh nicht relevant, ob das ausverkauft war oder nicht. Du zahlst immer grundsätzlich nach Fläche,
und nicht nach Hörern. Das wäre natürlich dann eigentlich auch ganz nett, wenn man da mal irgendwie so ein bisschen automatisierteren Kram, dass man eben so, ne, Anzahl der Gäste und
so weiter äh könnte man direkt, wenn wenn man da oder ein ähnliches Modell mit reinigen direkt nochmal eher so diese Beziehung zwischen Musikern und ähm,
und Fans irgendwie stärken und so. Aber im Moment sieht's eben so aus, als hätten wir all das nicht und diese GEMA,
Drehte also wirklich durch, ja und ähm zeigt also auch, also mit diesem.
Was mich da jetzt wirklich, ich habe ja noch vor einigen Folgen auch gesagt, dass die GEMA ja eigentlich,
schon zu den Guten gehört und da durchaus mal Ausschüttung an die an die Künstler auftreten. Aber wenn man sich diese wenn man sich das anschaut wie.
Also wenn so ein so ein Verein intern so eine so eine ganz klar von unten nach oben Verteilung auch nochmal hat,
und irgendwie da ein riesen, riesen Kohle für diesen administrativen Teil irgendwie versenkt, ne?
Sich irgendwie halbe Million Euro bezahlte Vorstände gönnt, ja? Das macht einfach nicht den Eindruck,
dass das irgendwie ein besonders karitatives Unterfangen sei, was die da was die da betreiben, ne? Und wenn,
Also so insgesamt, wie jetzt auch dieses dieses Club ähm Sterben, was sie da durchaus auf jeden Fall, also wenn das so passiert, ja, ich meine
ähm das wird äh einige Clubs sehr stark behindern. Er sagte dann diese diese äh freundliche Frau Sticher, die ich übrigens zu jeder, also kann ich Journalisten nur nahelegen,
irgendwas mit GEMA ist, ne.
Gabi Schlicher fragen, so, die erklärt das in Ruhe, ne? Die erklärt das ordentlich, die kann man also kann man auch zu wetten, dass einladen oder so, ne, die macht das super. Und ähm die sagte dann nämlich, ja, ähm
Ja, ja, ähm, es gibt, das stimmt, es gibt niemanden, der irgendwie unsere Tarifreform gutheißt,
Und deswegen soll's ja auch irgendwann so eine Schiedsgerichtentscheidung geben und die ganzen Clubs haben ja auf jeden Fall die Möglichkeit, ähm die Kohle, die sie jetzt nach der neuen Tarifreform,
und Schulden auf ein Treuhänderkonto zu zu schicken. Und wenn dann irgendwann in anderthalb Jahren die Schiedsgerichte
Entscheidung ist, dann können die Clubs ja ihre paar hunderttausend Euro, die sie dann da reingesemmelt haben, könnten sie die wieder haben, wenn sie äh Recht bekämen, ne.
Vielleicht unter Umständen, ja. Mhm.
Ja, also deutscher äh Hotel und Gastgewerbeverbande sind alle irgendwie dagegen gerade und ähm ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, dass ich das auch für,
verständlich halte, ne? Also zehn Prozent des des Eintritts beim Club klingt erstmal nicht so,
Klingt ja erstmal nicht so viel, aber wenn man, also wer mal ernsthaft irgendwie so was betrieben hat, äh der weiß schon, dass also in einigen Berliner Clubs mit mit zehn, zwölf Euro,
der Eintritt eigentlich doch relativ human ist. Ich sage nicht, dass das ein billiges Vergnügen ist, aber ähm im Vergleich zu dem, was man dort drinnen dann geboten bekommt,
sind diese Eintrittsgelder relativ human. Und wenn man sich überlegt, was,
Also was passieren wird dieser dieser Gamerkram, das wird jetzt ähm,
Natürlich werden nicht die Clubbetreiber das einfach hinnehmen, diesen, diese Mehrkosten, dann werden die natürlich auf die Besucher umlegen. Und dann sind wir die äh,
Sind wir ja sowieso, der kleine Mann, den du kennst, der kleine Mann ist immer dran.
Gibt's da eine Liste wer diese dreitausendvierhundert Leute eigentlich sind?
Ähm gehe ich von aus, ja.
Ich meine, dass die irgendwie schon mal bekannt geworden oder als die irgendwie.
Ähm weiß ich jetzt nicht, ich weiß ja nicht, worauf du da jetzt hinaus willst. Also wahrscheinlich kann man's nicht denken, wer's ist, ne? Es werden alle größeren äh.
Gut, man kann sich ein paar denken, ne.
Ich frage mich, warum die Loyalität so mit diesem Verein äh überhaupt so groß ist bei diesen Urhebern. Ich meine äh was was bitte äh bilden die sich eigentlich ein? Ja, also es,
Grad diese ganze äh Hyperventilierende äh Schnappatmung getragene Diskussion ums wie urheberrecht der letzten Wochen da die in den Medien ausgefochten wurde, die wir ja auch schon angesprochen haben.
Die machte auch wirklich an den Eindruck auf mich, dass wirklich also so viele Leute von den äh aus der Urheberseite, ja,
die es ja eigentlich gehen sollte. Überhaupt gar nicht verstehen, was da vor sich geht.
Nee, das tun sie auch nicht, aber die die also die die Begründung, geh mal Mitglied zu werden, ist ähm schon relativ klar, weil ähm,
Also mir kann da eigentlich nichts passieren, außer dass die für dich Inkasso machen und dir Kohle überweisen.
Kann, dir kann auch passieren, dass sie dir halt keine Kohle überweisen.
Ja, dann hast du eben kein.
Im Prinzip sehr wohl gehört wirst und deine Musik genutzt wird, also der eigentliche Anspruch mit wenn mein Zeug genutzt wird, dann werde ich als Urheber auch vergütet, der stimmt ja so nicht.
Also der ist für manche vielleicht wahr, ja, aber die meisten werden äh manche werden übervergütet und die meisten werden wahrscheinlich chronisch untervergütet.
Ja, ja, genau, ja, klar.
Warum sollte man sowas toll finden?
Besser weiß.
Ja ja. Ja.
Ja und ähm da da arbeitet die Gamer ja jetzt gerade dran, das zu ändern und äh das machen sie, wie gesagt, äh sehr gut, also die Personalie Schlicher ist da ähm,
Gold fährt, ja. Übrigens die GEMA-Website funktioniert gerade nicht. Ich wundere mich, woran das wohl liegt. Von hier, ja, die sind also wahrscheinlich grade unter Dedos-Attacke, die Internet äh Bürgerwacht äh,
Internetbürgerwehr, rächt sich.
Streamen wir gerade live.
Nee, dass ich äh das ging auch, glaube ich, die Tage über Twitter. Aber gerade die Gamer, ja da hatten sie sich ja auch beliebt mitgemacht, ne? Das irgendwie sieht Attacken hatten und dann haben sie da äh Hausdurchsuchungen äh durchführen lassen bei den äh.
Bei einigen der IP-Adressen, Inhabern und so. Also die die GEMA ähm Flauschkanone äh feuert aus allen Löchern, ja, also die die machen sich überall beliebt, ja.
Eine gewisse Nervosität ist auf jeden Fall schon zu spüren, ne. Tja, schauen wir mal. Gut, haben wir das Thema durch? Haben wir. Was gibt's denn sonst noch so Schönes.
Ja, eigentlich nicht so viel. Kurze Meldung, eigentlich nur Karrelle der EU-Kommissar für Handel.
Hat dann äh kurz den,
ähm EU-Parlament, welches ja am vierten Juli, der sich ja im Rahmen der nächsten Woche ähm abspielen wird über Acta entscheiden soll,
Äh an die hat er sich gewendet und hat gesagt, äh hier, äh übrigens, wenn ihr äh dagegen stimmt,
sage ich euch jetzt schon mal, äh dass die Kommission auch weiterhin das derzeitige Verfahren vor dem ähm EuGH verfolgen wird.
Und ein negatives Vatum Votum,
wird dieses Verfahren vor dem EuGH nicht beenden. Ja, es geht also um die Prüfung der äh mit der mit dem EU-Vertrag Vereinbarkeit,
Von Akta, also da da lässt die Kommission dann nicht von ab.
Hat in dieser Karie die Gurt selbst dafür gestimmt oder dagegen? Was macht's?
Na ja, ich meine, der wird auf jeden Fall dafür stimmen, ja, der ist ja, der ist der eine der treibenden Kräfte hinter Acta. Und sagt,
er geht davon aus, dass das Gericht dann, also der EUGH befindet, dass AKTA äh im vollen Einklang mit den Verträgen der äh Europäischen Union ist und wenn das Gericht diese Entscheidung trifft,
denn will er einfach einen zweiten Antrag auf Genehmigung an das europäische Parlament stellen. Ähm.
Einfach so lange abstimmen lassen, bis man das passende Ergebnis äh hat.
Ja? Und sagt dann also wörtlich wohl, äh ob das Parlament das in dieser oder der nächsten Wahlperiode äh betrachten wird, nicht also an ihn, ne. Das ist ähm das schon spannend. Also zu sagen, ja okay, übrigens, wenn ihr das ablehnt, dann knalle ich euch das einfach nächste Woche wieder auf den Tisch,
ähm das ist eine Taktik ähm.
Wird bestimmt erfolgreich sein, also könnte dann mittelfristig auch zu seiner Absetzung führen, wenn er es da übertreibt, aber ist schwer einzuschätzen.
Es ist wirklich ähm fällt mir jetzt nicht mehr viel zu ein, ja.
Also so, aber sagen wir's so, ähm er, er nennt das Kind wenigstens beim Namen und ähm sagt, dass es wieder Acta sein wird und dass da auch immer noch Akta dran stehen wird, ja? Das einzige, was äh der Unterschied
zu dem, was was grundsätzlich zu erwarten ist, ist ja einfach nur, dass er sogar zugibt, dass weiter Akta dranstehen wird. Was sonst zu erwarten ist, dass man das Gleiche nochmal bekommt und eben was anderes draufsteht.
Er will jetzt offensichtlich nur diese diesen,
diesen Heckmeck gar nicht machen. Insofern ist er relativ ehrlich, ist er zu erwarten, dass ähm also beobachten wir überall, dass eben ähm die Kämpfe im Bereich der Netzpolitik nicht an einem,
mit einer Entscheidung oder mit einer Gesetzesinitiative dann endgültig erledigt sind. Da beobachten wir in allen anderen Bereichen auch, ja? Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder so. Dass der Kram einfach wiederkommt. Und versuchen wir es nochmal, ja.
Und da sagt er jetzt auch halt relativ nett von ihm.
So und dann gab's noch ähm das Thema hatten wir auch vor einigen Wochen hier schon mal angesprochen, die Störerhaftung.
Da haben sich jetzt einige äh Mitglieder des Vereins digitale Gesellschaft, die äh juristisch bewandert sind, zusammengesetzt und einen äh Gesetzentwurf ähm.
Also hier geht's um offenes WLAN, et cetera, wenn eine Kneipe WLAN anbietet, äh haftet sie dafür, wenn jemand darüber irgendeinen Verstoß äh betreibt.
Genau. Und äh dieser Gesetzesentwurf soll sich genau dagegen wenden und sagen, okay, hier ähm,
ein großer Provider wie T-Mobile oder TR Online oder wie die dann heißen sind natürlich auch von der Haftung für das, was ihre Nutzer machen
freigestellt und das möchten wir für die Mini Provider, die ein WLAN irgendwo zur Verfügung stellen. Bitteschön,
auch so haben. Es gab vor allem für Privatpersonen ja im Mai zweitausendzehn äh so ein Urteil,
Da ging's, glaube ich, um irgendeinen Film oder so. Da hatte eine Frau unbeabsichtigt offenes WLAN. Das war so,
Ein unverschlüsseltes WLAN nennt es sich jeder einen anmelden konnte und wo der dann tatsächlich noch vor Gericht eben schuldig beziehungsweise nicht schuldig, aber haftbar
für das äh File-Sharing, was dann irgendein Nachbar oder so über ihren über ihren Anschluss gemacht hat, äh wurde sie dann haftbar. Ähm.
Jetzt hat äh die sind diesen Gesetzesentwurf veröffentlicht und drangeschrieben, wir schenken ihn der Politik, ähm könnt ihr jetzt so ähm nutzen,
das ist also,
Das heißt natürlich eigentlich, dass es niemand machen wird, weil es wird ja keine Partei ähm sich vor den Karren spannen lassen. Rechne ich jetzt zumindest mit. Ich glaube nicht, dass eine Partei sagt, super hier die gegessenen Gesetzesentwurf, den den schleppen wir jetzt mal durch. Ähm.
Zeigen, gibt ja genug Gesetzentwürfe von anderen Lobbyorganisationen, die schon so mehr oder weniger übernommen werden, äh ob die entsprechenden
Punkt erreicht hat, dass äh äh sei in Frage gestellt. Aber es generell, denke ich, ist das schon mal der richtige Ansatz, weil man ja mit einem Gesetzesentwurf, also ich denke,
in Form eines Gesetzesentwurfes etwas vorzulegen, sagt ja, nicht unbedingt,
Genauso müsst ihr das machen, sondern A. Wir haben eine relativ klare Vorstellung davon, was eigentlich wirklich falsch ist. Hier haben wir mal in unseren Worten ausgedrückt,
wie man es konkret auch richtig tun könnte, dann kann man sich ja über die Details immer noch äh Gedanken machen, aber es ist natürlich
ein deutlich konkreterer und von daher eben auch sehr viel ähm,
kooperativerer äh politischer Schritt, als wenn man jetzt immer nur sagt, ihr seid alle doof, ähm weil so geht's ja nicht.
Und zeigt also der ist auch relativ kurz ähm stößt dann eben die Debatte an und das ist genau recht, dass man in der Saison sagen kann ähm hier wir haben euch mal aufgemalt, wie einfach das geht und das sind irgendwie zwei Sätze, die irgendwo noch mit dabei geschrieben werden müssen und die
ähm Telemediengesetz und so weiter, gibt's ja schon. Also ähm.
Wäre jetzt kein großer Akt das zu machen. Und dann kommt natürlich die Frage auf ja, aber ähm was ist denn dann los, wenn ähm.
Es würde ja die äh Verfolgung von Urheberrechtsverstößen ähm
erschweren und da kommt meines Erachtens die relativ sinnvolle Antwort zu sagen, wir wollen doch lieber äh eine kleine Anteil äh urheberrechtsverstöße
verfolgt haben,
lassen, als das ähm ein Unschuldiger bestraft wird, ja? Und das in dieser Unschuldige ist dann im Zweifelsfall jemand, der entweder wieder besseren Wissens oder aber mit guter Absicht handelt, nämlich, dass er Personen, die
vielleicht kein Internet haben oder an dem Ort, an dem sie sich gerade befinden, kein Internet haben, ein solches zur Verfügung stellen möchte, ja.
Ähm ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich darüber darauf schon verwiesen hatte, dass es von den,
frei funkeln, diese Initiative gibt mit den ich weiß gar nicht wie die hießen diese Boxen. Also die verteilen WLAN-Router haben hundert Stück, verteilen die an Kneipen und so ähm und diese diese Router machen offenes WLAN.
Und tummeln dann aber durch einen VPN nach Schweden
sodass dann da äh sodass du keine äh Probleme mit der Störerhaftung hast, ja.
Nicht gibt.
Nee, das das war jetzt irgend so ein das ist irgend so ein äh VPN Anbieter, ne, gibt's ja relativ viele VPN-Anbieter, die dann als Anonymisierungsdienste fungieren. Ähm und da gab's wohl offensichtlich einen VPN-Anbieter, der gesagt hat, zu diesem Zwecke spende ich euch irgendwie hundert Accounts.
Und äh das natürlich auch eine eine technische Möglichkeit der Umgehung, aber es kann's ja letztendlich nicht sein. Also äh dieses Problem, was da mit der jungen Dame besteht, deren offenes WLAN,
sie dann letztendlich vor Gericht verlieren lässt, äh,
Ein derartiger Umgang mit, sage ich mal, wie gesagt, entweder technischer Inkompetenz oder äh technischem Wohlwollen ähm,
sicherlich auch kein, kein gutes Signal.
Ja. Das war's schon, oder? Sonst nichts passiert.
Gibt's Ausblicke?
Ja, vielleicht zu erwähnen äh Julian Assange, äh Entscheidung ist doch nicht gefallen. Ich hatte ja erst gesagt, dass ich davon ausgehe, dass die dass dass sie bald schon fällt. Ähm aber das sieht jetzt eher wieder nach etwas aus, was relativ lange dauern wird.
Hm. Ähm jetzt sitzt er erstmal da.
Jetzt sitzt er erstmal da und.
Botschaft auch in der Lage ist, seine Fernsehsendung zu produzieren.
Ja, es ist halt, kommt halt drauf an, wie das mit der Störerhaftung für Botschaften ist, ob der da Internet kriegt oder nicht.
Und er hat sich auf jeden Fall auch schon zu der zu der Problematik geäußert, dass ihm irgendwie durchaus einleuchtet, dass er, wenn er den Raum, wenn er da irgendwie versucht, den Raum zu verlassen, dass er wieder in Kennen kommt. Ähm.
Hat er sich dazu geäußert.
Ja, hat er so, also sieht er wohl so ein, also den Plan irgendwie da nochmal mit dem Helikopter Verfolgungsjagd oder so. Ähm,
Der besteht jetzt erstmal nicht. Hm, also da da bleibt's spannend, ja.
Veranstaltung irgendwas.
Ja, ach so, genau, ja, wie gesagt, am vierten ist die Akte-Abstimmung, da wird dann jetzt auch eingeladen zum, äh, Abend,
bei grill und alkoholisch und Kaltgetränk den Etappensieg zu feiern.
Am vierten, ja.
Mhm. Okay. Links in unseren Shownotes. Ne.
Ja. Können wir aufhören jetzt.
Der letzte Link direkt neben dem Flatterbutton für für Linus. Wenn Linus, Linus, Linus nimmt es sehr persönlich mit dem Flatterbutton, ja?
Also ich mache das hier alles nur aus Spaß und ich möchte, dass dann da wirklich bei dem wenigsten irgendwie eine Zahl ist, wo ich sage, ja guck mal, das ist eine schöne Zahl.
Eine schöne Zahl.
Eine schöne Zahl. Und bei meinen Twitter-Followern soll er auch eine schöne Zahl.
Ja, da muss auch mehr hin, da ist auch keine schöne Zeit. Sonst bin ich mit allen Sachen zufrieden. Super.
Super. Okay, dann war's das hier. Die launische Ausgabe Nummer dreißig. Bis bald. Tschau, tschau.
Tschau, tschau.